This is the kilogram. Not a kilogram, the
kilogram.
The British National Standard Kilogram,
at the National Physical Laboratory in Teddington.
It's a lump of platinum-iridium alloy,
it's kept in a very very secure safe just
under here,
and it weighs... well, one kilogram.
Mass measurement around the world needs to
be equivalent.
So if I buy something in America that's a
milligram, or a kilogram, or 100 tonnes,
I need to know that it's equivalent to a milligram,
or a kilogram, or 100 tonnes in the UK.
The real key areas of interest, where the
uncertainties are very important,
are, for example, the pharmaceutical industry
where you're dealing with very, very small
quantities of active ingredients
and you have to measure them very, very accurately.
So when, say, your bathroom scales were manufactured,
they were tested against equipment that was
tested against equipment that,
several chains down the line later,
was tested against something like this.
And this was tested against the International
Prototype Kilogram in Paris.
And this is a really weird thing to wrap your
head around,
but that one in Paris? It always weighs a
kilogram.
It doesn't matter if it's gained a tiny amount
of mass from adsorbing air contaminants,
or lost a tiny amount when it was cleaned.
It is one kilogram.
We know that the International Prototype is
probably not stable,
because all its copies are unstable relative
to itself.
But there's nothing above the International
Prototype that you can compare it with
to tell whether it's changing or not.
Defining international constants by a physical
thing is... not ideal,
so in the next few years, scientists round
the world
are deciding what the 21st century standard
should be.
The formal definition will be based on physics,
likely Planck's Constant,
but how do you make that into a physical thing?
There are two options: first, a fixed number
of atoms.
You can manufacture 1kg sphere of almost-pure,
single-crystal silicon relatively easily.
What you have to measure here is the lattice
spacing,
ie how far the atoms are apart in the sphere,
and the volume of the sphere. And both of
those
are measurements you can make at a level of
uncertainty
where you can generate a sphere which has
an accuracy
of a part in 10-to-the-8, roughly.
The downside of that is it costs you €2.5million
for a sphere.
Finding the kilogram that way seems to make
sense.
We're measuring mass, after all.
But there is an alternative which could be
cheaper and easier,
although it isn't quite as obvious.
The watt balance is an electrical way of measuring
mass.
This is a way of demonstrating simply how
a watt balance works.
We have a loudspeaker here
and if I pass a current through the coil of
the loudspeaker,
you can see that the cone will move up and
move down.
If I was to put a mass on here,
if I restore the position of the mass,
the current I need to do that is a measure
of the weight of that mass.
The problem I've got is that I don't know
the strength of the field of the magnet,
or the number of turns on the coil.
And I can do a second experiment by moving
the cone of the speaker, like that.
If I was to measure the velocity with which
I was moving that,
and also measure the voltage which was produced,
that would tell me that quantity and allow
me to eliminate it from the two experiments.
Which, if done accurately, is enough to work
out the weight of that mass.
Whichever approach gets chosen,
there will still be physical reference kilograms
in the world.
They're not going away. But for the first
time,
we're going to have something absolute to
compare them against.
Thank you to everyone at the National Physical
Laboratory!
They have a YouTube channel that you can check
out,
and they occasionally hold open days. Details
are on their web site.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name
here!]